Hevy buddy welcome to lab coding with
Jessie I'm Jessie and today I'm gonna
try to fix the problem that we
encountered yesterday and there were a
few reasons why that was happening and
so I'm gonna share with you a couple of
reasons and then we're gonna try to fix
it if you didn't see yesterday's video
here's a quick recap of what we tried to
do we started up a sequel a my sequel
database on Google's cloud platform and
we took our wordpress my sequel database
that we've been using for this project
and we made a copy and then we sent that
copy over to the new database that we're
running on Google's cloud platform so
the database is there the tables are
there we verified that but we couldn't
connect we were attempting to host
WordPress with now from site and we
couldn't get it to connect to the
database and that's kind of where we
left off yesterday so I thought a lot
about it
I couldn't even though I stopped working
I did not stop thinking about that
problem which I don't know if that
happens to you all but that frequently
happens to me like if there's a problem
I didn't solve I I just keep thinking
about it all the time I think maybe it'd
be better if I just worked until I fixed
it and then I could be at peace but in
this case I think I've found the
solution but I haven't had time to test
it yet the solution is from what I
understand in addition to a few other
adjustments we're going to make a proxy
because we authorize some IP addresses
some networks unfortunately when you
host the site with now you don't have
than IP address it changes too often so
they don't even give you the IP address
of your your instance of whatever you're
running with now so in cases where you
can't give them an IP address Google's
cloud sequel offers the option of
running a proxy and accessing it like
that there is also a further
complication that Harshit found and that
was we were the example we were using to
run WordPress with now was assuming that
we were using AWS and their security so
we may need to go in and disable some of
that stuff too but first I definitely
want to get this proxy set up so I
haven't done this before we're gonna go
through it together I have the
instructions up here somewhere I'm gonna
paste in a link to the instructions you
all can check that out with me and let's
see hey hey everybody see there's a few
you saying hi yeah let's let's get
started so as soon as I find those
instructions I'm gonna send them all to
you and we're gonna get started so here
they are there in the chat now if you
have trouble clicking on that - and it
doesn't open then try copy and pasting
it and
alright I'm gonna make sure I have this
up on one of my other screens and we can
get started with that
one computer if my fan is running too
loud and that's what's bothering you let
me know
I tried closing down as much as I could
and I can't figure out what is running
and causing the fan to to run an
overdrive like that alright so let's
move over to the split screen there we
are
okay Harshit is making a poor request
right now to fix some of those issues so
I'm gonna wait and pull down the latest
changes before we do anything on this
repo that you see here and what I'm
gonna do instead is go through let's
start this timer and let me pull this
over here and let's go through some of
these instructions try to get this
working all right so we can see here the
proxy what it's going to do for us is
it's gonna let us access our server our
database here without whitelisting IP
addresses so that's what we we can't
whitelist because we don't have you know
a static IP address or even really a
range that we could set so I guess we
could y'all can read this if you want
more info but the graphics are nice so
this is how it's going to connect
instead of going directly to cloud
sequel obviously the proxy lets us go to
the proxy and then go to cloud sequel so
pretty simple concepts I at least I
think let me know if it's if it's not I
have been reading up on this for a while
so if you I may have a slight advantage
that understanding it
okay all right so we've enabled the API
so we did that yesterday
we need these GCP authentication
credentials so I'm just going to open
that another window for right now found
a database user account password we set
that up yesterday your instance must
have an external IP address which we we
have all right awesome
so let's let's try this out and try this
out on our I'm using a Mac right now so
let's get to our command line and let me
organize this a bit better let's go over
to our command line and yeah I'll just
open up a new window here all right so
we're gonna download this great
downloaded so quickly and then we're
gonna make it executable great
laughs connections we need to provide it
with this info so we should have all
this info state of kung-fu application
be Santa Claus don't find credentials
okay great
okay I'm just scanning over this I think
it's always a good practice to read all
the instructions before doing it I don't
know what I'm cooking it always helps
with the recipe if I know what's gonna
happen ahead of time so I'm not gonna
read it all I'm just gonna scan a bit
all right this is good we're gonna they
have a github page just for this that
we're using which is awesome
all right so we are just testing this
right now but eventually we would have
to go to this step if we end up using
this so let's go now I can't find where
I left off all right we'll see how do we
want to provide these credentials
you create a credential file
mmm
okay
all right so we have a few more people
joining us for those of you that are
joining I just want to reiterate we're
going through this process I've never
done this before so that's why there's a
bit of silence on my part from kind of
reading over this I am gonna check the
chat because it looks like there's a lot
in here
okay so it does look like hardship made
a pull request there so when the time
comes we're going to bring in his pool
requests before we attempt to connect
everything the wordpress instance to
this database okay
I'll go through if you have asked some
questions I will answer those questions
as soon as our Pomodoro timer is
obviously about 17 minutes left here at
this point I mean let me paste this in
the chat as well and then that way you
can check out the tool that we're using
that we just loaded that I just loaded
locally and I guess for those of you
that weren't here earlier here's the
page for the instructions were following
okay so here's some example in vacations
so let's check this
hmm
I guess we can try one of these
all right so let me try let's move over
to here just to change this up so we do
need to replace
you need
so I'm trying to figure out where
they're expecting this to be run from
alright let's see alright so I'm not
exactly sure let me tell you what I'm
thinking right now what I'm not sure
about I may just end up copying some
stuff and throwing it in the command
line just to see if it works because we
read up here a little earlier I guess up
here first it was talking about loading
this proxy on your local machine and
then it was saying something about
running it in the Google cloud platform
console which which I mean that's
definitely two different things so I'm
trying to to figure out what they want
that's
all right so we have that club's sequel
proxy
all right good it's not a directory
let's see if we can just writers do run
run is not a command what's the
equivalent command next
actually maybe I just look here
okay of course
all right so we definitely need to fall
credentials which is what we're trying
to do over here
I just need to figure out what the
credentials are and actually this this
will help okay we have this info I'm
just gonna grab it from
okay and
I wonder if this is gonna be the
database name let's see if this is what
they wanted all right I'm not sure if
they want like the main name for the
Google cloud account or the database
username we'll find out
all right so let's try this out now
what's WordPress command I found all
right so obviously that was not what
they needed so let's try it again
I shoot it's treating it like two
different commands
all right
just i'm checking back in the chat to
see if see if i've lost all of you since
I'm a bit lost myself alright so I mean
at this point I'm just gonna try a few
more variations hunting it's on this
command see if I can get something
different to come up even if it's a
different error message that's gonna be
progress if it doesn't work after a few
more tries then I'll just go back to the
documentation make sure I didn't miss a
step all right
you know what let's let me double check
this I think there was something
yeah maybe sis we're doing this locally
right now
all right so anyway this is what I was
looking for that enable the API I just
want to double check that we have
enabled the proper API
okay
all right now that that's enabled I'm
just gonna try to run this again all
right nothing ok let's try these
instructions for now just to get
something working and then we can we can
move on I mean I think it it may it at
the very least help us to rule out like
where where am I making this mistake at
if you haven't already SOG click
all right so there is a g-cloud command
line tool awesome
see
guess what downloaded that real quick
welcome to the cloud SDK yay yes yes
great
so we just installed this Google cloud
stuff g-cloud init
would you like to login sure
take your club project to use five
all right awesome okay it looks like
we're all set then to continue on with
these instructions and I'm gonna
minimize these looks like we're almost
ready for Question Time
so I'll hear a little beep soon maybe
done that let's use this QuickStart
we've already done this it's details
connected since this is connection name
we've already done that so you already
have copied the instance connection name
start the proxy in its own terminal she
can monitor its output we're gonna
replace instant connection name let's
just copy that and replace instance
connection name with this
it's
cannot find credentials
login
so we redid this
I didn't
let me run this and then we'll do
questions
Hey great wonderful all right so we got
down to this step for it to work cool
all right so that's like not nearly
where we need to be at but it's the
first step let's take a short break and
I'm gonna answer some questions
Jeremy asked at a high level what's the
value add such purpose for using the
proxy the proxy allows us will let me
back up so normally you would have an IP
address whitelist and only connect
incoming connections from those IP
addresses would be allowed for that
sequel database but we we want to be
able to connect to it without having the
whitelist an IP address so that's what
the proxy enables us to do is to still
have incoming connections from whatever
IP address and have that word if for
this particular project we need that
because the place where I would like to
host WordPress from WordPress needs to
communicate with this database with that
place who's gonna have variable IP
addresses so that's about as high level
as I could make it I guess
Stephen says so lost but I totally have
a video to refer to if I ever need this
yeah for sure
world says you have to give Google your
database passwords well essentially we
we've created a database with Google's
cloud sequel service so Google is
running our database so obviously they
they have our passwords oh cool oh man I
went to grab more coffee and my coffee
mug is out of coffee I mean like in the
grand scheme of things that's no big
deal but really that's kind of like the
worst when it happens all right so I
don't have any more questions right now
so I think I'm gonna go right back into
another Pomodoro session and I think I
only want to do one more poem into our
session I have a lot of paperwork and to
do from my last trip for my last
conference and somebody's gonna help me
with that since I never remember how to
do it right and I also have to pick up
my son from school so I have to leave
the office early so anyway I want to get
some stuff done now as quickly as I can
all right so we can test our connection
by going replacing user name with your
my sequel user name okay cool
I just like to edit these oops I guess I
forgot to copy I just like to edit these
in my code editor username shoot
let's try this let's try like that and
then I want to put so I want to just go
into that WordPress database so that's
how I'm gonna modify that just a bit and
let's see where am i what do I need to
run this here no or in another no I
don't know
all right let me run it from here do I
not
I'm thinking I thought I had this tab
open but I haven't opened on my laptop
right next to me so obviously this is
not gonna work for right now let me I
need SSH into somewhere else that's my
seat
all right I'm gonna stalling my sequel
really quick on my other screen there we
go
all right let's see if I have it yet
oops you open up a new one
No why is it not found still
mmm
all right that's not cool I just went
through the install process to this and
now it's not working
all right well let me go back
service account
definitely skip this part before
alright so we have this proxy running
maybe
there we go my sequel shell okay
I let's see
let's see what I can do then now that we
have this started
mmm
all right let's try
that's other way
all right cool so it looks like we can
use this let's try it
mm-hmm all right what was the unexpected
identifier let's try it without this
then
let me let me check this
robocop said if everything worked
without warning that would be too good
to be true
yeah for sure I mean I expected that we
would have some trouble since I've never
attempted anything like this before I do
wish that it was going slightly better
but
okay Jeremy Miller saying pee without a
pass that a password
let's see still interesting
let's get try this one
all right
this is kind of a dead end right now
need help troubleshooting it's worth a
shot here
hmm all right I don't think any of those
supply mad Duchess says I saying I had
it on UNIX sockets but it was supposed
to be TCP yeah I try the TCP already and
it did not work I mean maybe
I mean right now I we just keep getting
that error like a syntax error let's see
alright cool so I just went there in my
browser just to see what would happen so
at least where it's registering
Oh actually you know what I could use
let me try this up let me open this
sequel operation studio and then I'll
see if we can can do this so let's do
this and we'll do password and see if
this works
mmm not looking good I'm not reading
anything here nope
server was not found or not accessible
okay shoot
I mean I could try
okay you try running it like this
hmm
let's see check stackoverflow question
alright but I'm gonna check uh some out
of this screen click the
okay cool I did check out that question
so let's try it out
alright so evidently that is not working
let's go to yeah mmm wrong way cool
there we go
not giving me anything right now let's
see if this is shown anything you know
just break this out so we can see what's
going on in
maybe I should put in that this might
have to Oh Jeremy thank you
I always mess that up ever not connected
you know maybe I should put in
put this into
hmm
it's Jeremy I'm glad you I was just
reading that in the Stack Overflow thing
to do it that way so so if it's my
sequel jazz we can go connect
and then at 0.01 0-6
yes
oh alright let me try it with and let me
go into LastPass guess that password
it's very long
hmm
all right well my second Pomodoro
session just finished
I just found someone else who's giving a
similar error
Stephen says this is a long way from me
building front insights and client
dashboards yeah this it's a little
different than what we're used to
it's cool to do new things though I
don't know it's fun
definitely stretches the brain a bit hmm
well we made some progress today right
wasn't definitely not mission
accomplished yet but made some progress
trying to think just trying to see if
there are any flags that I could use
hmm
world says are you afraid that Google
give you a bill for like 1k or something
for using cloud uh no I'm not really
afraid of that you don't want to see how
much I've been built so far I don't know
let's check it out
billing
I guess nothing so far
yeah I guess nothing nothing so far
that's cool I mean I had I'd actually
only plan on having this up just during
yesterday stream but we didn't get done
what I wanted to get done so that's why
it's still up John Hanson says would it
be worth trying out your commands in the
Google cloud show hmm sorry within the
Google cloud platform console well the
thing I was I wanted to do was I wanted
to be able to connect from from outside
the college because we you know we
already were able to connect using the
console and Google cloud platform
all right I'm just scanning to see if
there are any other questions
all right Hodor says I'm looking to make
an electron and react app is you're
setting up an electron project still the
go-to yeah that's the latest that I've
done with electron so check that out and
then check out the project oh excuse me
check out the project that we started in
that video the the github repo for that
to see where we're at with it
it's not you know up-to-date as much
up-to-date as it could be but I think it
should give you an idea of how to get
started up what Stephen says you need
some coffee yeah I need and he is
something all right cool right I need to
I need to end this dream and go do my
paperwork and stuff before I have to
pick up my son so thank you all for
watching sorry we didn't finish this
again I don't know if it was painful
watching at all it was a little bit
painful for me going through this still
I I mean I still liked learning more
about this and figuring some of the
stuff out so you know maybe I'll work on
a little bit later at home or something
like that I kind of don't want to do a
whole another stream with this stuff so
we'll see what happens
tomorrow it's almost Friday yeah I'll
try to do stream tomorrow know whether I
get this working you're not I'll try to
stream about something so all RoboCup
says the best dream by far I don't know
if you're being sarcastic or what but I
don't know maybe it's bad
watch me struggle on on that end but I
see
alright Julio's sending me something to
check out so I will check that out I'm
copying and pasting that right now to my
browser and thank you it's season
okay all right I'm gonna end this dream
for real now thank you all so much for
watching and for all your help hopefully
I'll be back tomorrow and until then
have a great day